احداث كرويه نادره والثاقتها عدسات
المصورين من اولى بطولات المونديال دعونا
ناخذكم في رحله بالابيض والاسود للحظات
مضى على بعضها نحو 90 عاما
كاميرات المصورين اختلفت وتغيرت عدساتهم
واليه التصوير لكن شغف الاعلاف من محبي
كره القدم لم يختلف حتى اليوم هذه الصوره
توثيق الملصق الرسمي لاول بطوله عالميه
لكره القدم تحت مسمى كاس العالم
1930 كانت هذه البطوله فريده من نوعها فهي
الوحيده التي لم تتضمن تصفيات مؤهلتا كل
المنتخبات المنتسبات للاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم دعايات للمشاركه بها لكن لم يشارك
فيها سوى 13 منتخب بسبب المده الزمنيه
طويله للرحله الى الاوروغواي
في السفر العاليه قابل المحيط الاطلسي
هكذا بدل مشهد المهيب في ملعب العاصمه
منتديو
93,000 حضروا للاستمتاع بالمباراه
النهائيه التي جمعت المنتخب الارجنتيني
ومنتخب الاوروغواي صاحب الارض وانتهت بفوز
الاخير بنتيجه اربعه اهداف لهدفين لتصبح
اول دوله تفوز بكاس العالم
البطوله التاليه للمونديال كانت في
ايطاليا وهي اول بطوله تلعب بها تصفيات
مؤهله 16 دوله تاهلت من 32 دوله لكن
العديد من الدول قررت مقاطعه المونديال
لاسباب مختلفه
الاوروغواي حامل لقب قرر مقاطعه البطوله
بسبب مقاطعه الدول الاوروبيه للمشاركه في
البطوله الاولى التي استضافها قبل اربع
سنوات
المباراه النهائيه للمونديال
2934 جمعت منتخبي تشيكوسلوفاكيا ونظيره
الايطالي صاحب الارض توج المنتخب الايطالي
بهذه النسخه الى فرنسا حيث مونديال
1938 في هذه البطوله غابت ايضا العديد من
الدول
لاقامه بطوله على الاراضي القاره
الاوروبيه الحرب الاهليه في اسبانيا
غيبتنا ايضا عن المونديال المباراه
النهائيه جامعه ايطاليا والمجر وانتهت
بحمل الطاليان للكاس بعد فوزهم باربعه
اهداف لهدفين بعد هذه البطوله اندلعت
شراره الحرب العالميه الثانيه وتوقف معها
شغف محبي كره القدم ل 12 عاما متوسطلا في
عام 1950
السؤلفت البطوله الدوليه واضادت معها
صيحات عشاق كره القدم بقى نظمت البطوله في
البرازيل وصولا الى المباراه النهائيه على
ملعب ماراكانا بين اوروغواي وراقيس سامبا
وبحضور قياسيه بلغ نحو 200 الف متفرجين
وهو الرقم الذي ظل صامدا عبر التاريخ
كاكثر المباريات النهائيه حضورا للجماهير
حيث فاز منتخب الاوروغواي باللقب الثاني
له في بطولات كاس العالم ثم توالت البطوله
واستمرت معها احلام المنتخبات وشرف
الجماهير العاشقه للصاحره المستديره